MAX SALTONSTALL: On this
episode of "Stack Chat,"
Spotify Infrastructure
Engineer Matt Brown
talks about how his team
approached the move to Google
Cloud and Kubernetes.
Thanks for joining me, Matt.
So I want you to tell
me, first, just how
is Spotify using GCP behind
the scenes a little bit?
MATT BROWN: So at
Spotify we use what
feels like every part of
GCP in some area of Spotify.
And we've moved over the
past couple of years really
everything we do to GCP.
So we use products
on the data side--
Bigtable, Cloud SQL, BigQuery
pops up for many things.
The area that I
work in, which is
an infrastructure for
back end services,
historically we use a lot
of Google computation,
But that's moving mostly over
to Kubernetes engine now.
MAX SALTONSTALL:
And then you had
to choose between Kubernetes
and managed Kubernetes on GCP.
So how did that choice
play out for you?
MATT BROWN: So really,
as we were starting
to think and plan for when do
we want to move to Kubernetes,
we were already moving away
from having our own data
centers to running pretty much
everything in Google Cloud.
So the idea of setting up
our own Kubernetes clusters,
learning how to manage
the networking, all
of those things,
just never really
sounded very appealing to us.
The big promise for
Google Cloud for us
is all of the managed
services we can use.
And then our
engineers can move up
a layer in what we're
worrying about and not
worrying about the low
layer things so much.
So a managed service like GKE
was really perfect for us.
MAX SALTONSTALL: So what
other kinds of benefits
did your engineering teams get
then from making that shift?
MATT BROWN: So a huge one is
that in our current platform
in HELIOS, it's not very
easy to do auto scaling.
So teams tend to have to do
capacity planning every once
in a while to figure out how
many virtual machines would
they need for peak traffic,
something like that.
And then as a result, most
teams are over-provisioned
for a large amount of the time.
So auto scaling helps a lot with
that because not only can they
respond to shifts in
traffic a lot more faster,
but they also just don't
have to be over-provisioned
and using so many resources.
MAX SALTONSTALL: As you're
making this transition,
how does this system handle
failure or degradation
of any of the
infrastructure or pieces?
MATT BROWN: So we use
regional clusters in GKE
so we can be deployed
across many zones.
Spotify runs across three
different regions in GCP.
So we're just relying on
those primitives, in a way,
for that type of reliability.
And then we also, as
an infrastructure team,
do a lot of practicing
around let's think
of a possible disaster--
somebody deleting a
cluster in the Cloud
console on accident, let's say--
let's practice
those things to make
sure we have good playbooks,
we know how to recover,
we can catch those with alerts.
Because we figure
eventually it's
going to happen in
production anyway,
so why not give us a
chance to practice it?
MAX SALTONSTALL: Are
there other things
that you could have done,
or encouraged others to do,
that would have
sped up this change?
MATT BROWN: I
would say one thing
that we found out
in doing this, going
through this whole process, that
we were a little bit pleasantly
surprised at is we didn't have
to do as much evangelizing
or motivation or having a
carrot stick to tell people
you need to move to Kubernetes.
Most engineering teams
were really excited.
And one thing that we found
worked the best was we
had a group of engineers who
weren't on the infrastructure
team--
they were just early adopters--
and they did a lot of work
in talking to other
engineers, writing blog posts,
giving talks at an
internal conference
we have to motivate
other people.
So one thing that I think we
could've done a little bit more
of was just trying to build
more of those champions
or evangelists.
It was a really
pleasant surprise,
but we could have
always had more.
MAX SALTONSTALL: Awesome.
Well, it sounds like
you're on the way,
and I look forward to hearing
more about it as you get
closer and closer to your goal.
Thanks very much for
joining me today.
MATT BROWN: Thanks
for having me.
MAX SALTONSTALL: If you
enjoyed this episodes,
check out the "Stack Chat"
playlist for more videos.
[MUSIC PLAYING]